I think it's fair to say that we are living
in the "I want to be a celebrity" era. And
even though there's nothing wrong with it,
there's a way to do it which is the right
way, and there is a way to do it which is
the wrong way. And if you take this route
and people figure it out, you don't get a
lot of good reputation.
I want to make sure I teach you how to be
bullet proof on the way you build your brand
and you build your name and for you to also
know who is legit on social media because,
look, if there's ever been a time when on
social media we've been naked, it's today.
Everybody today is naked.
Eight years ago you could have bought some
fake followers and fake things and people
would have gotten away with it and they would
say, oh my gosh, this guy's got such a big
following. Not today. There are tools to catch
everyone today with fake accounts or fake
followers or any of that.
So almost look at it as 1000 years ago you
and I, 100 years ago we were going to a local
bank, with our horse, 100 years ago, to get
a loan to buy a house. And we go to the bank
and say, hey, we want to buy a house. And
he says, well how do I know you can make the
payments? Believe me, I made all my payments.
How do I know? There's all this other stuff.
You can ask the neighbors. Okay, we'll give
you $50,000, $3,000 to buy a house, whatever
the number was back then.
They still didn't know. Today, you have a
FICA score. And today you can't go to the
bank and say, "Believe me. I'll make the car
payments. Believe me, I'll make the mortgage
payments." They're not going to give it to
you. They have ways of testing your credibility
with payments you make. That's called Experian,
TransUnion, and Equifax, I believe.
I'm going to talk about that today with social
media following. This got started for us,
the reason why Mario and I were talking and
a lot of you said, "Pat, should I buy a $1,000
program from this guy? This guy's selling
me something for 3 grand, should I buy from
him? Is this guy legit? He says he can help
me take my account to the next level. This
guy tells me he can get me on T.V. This guy
tells me he can. . . Look, I'm not here to
audit all those people for you. I'm not here
to do that for you. Okay? I'm not a consultant
to sit there and do this; I run a financial
firm. But I will give you direction on where
to go for you to do your own due diligence,
because at the end of the day, my goal is
to develop you into a leader, into an independent
entrepreneur that can do this on your own
without needing to message me every time to
say, "what do you think about this guy? What
do you think about that guy?"
So, when we recently hit 100,000 YouTube subs,
we started getting a lot of people saying,
"Pat, can we do a product placement on your
channel? Can you please use this product and
talk about it?" And very credible companies,
by the way. We're not talking about small
companies doing a million, two million, five
million a year. We're talking companies that
have products that they want us to talk about
and endorse and experience and how do I feel
about it, and if I like it, talk about it
with my users, and maybe give some away.
And so we kind of took a step back and then
we started getting people that want to collaborate
with us and especially now with Valuetainment,
I'm going to be launching a lot of new collaborators
to you, as the viewer on Valuetainment because
some of the ladies are asking, Pat, I want
to see the perspective of entrepreneurship
on the woman's side. No problem. We're going
to collaborate with some ladies and bring
it to you. Some people say, Pat, I want to
get to the style part, and this is why we
teamed up with Antonio Centeno from Wisconsin
who's got 750,000 subs at this point. Probably
by the time you watch it he's got a million.
He's got a very, very strong YouTube channel
and a company called Real Men, Real Style.
So, when we first started looking at the different
teams that were reaching out to us on YouTube,
it's a small community of people who have
100,000 plus subs, I noticed everybody's kind
of sizing each other up. Not posturing, but
it's kind of like, is he legit? Is he not
legit? And as we were going through this,
everyone has access to the same tools. Once
we started going through this, then Antonio
came here and we spent two, three days together,
and we said, wait a minute, this guy's legit.
We're legit. We hit it off. And then by the
time we're done, we're going to be doing some
major projects together that you'll hear about.
This is going to happen with many other names
that I'll give you as well. Kelly Nishimoto
was here from Cute Booty pants she makes the
Lexy Panterra award that got 90 million views
and she had a show, something borrowed something
new. She'll talk about that with the ladies
side. But we want to find out who's real and
who's not. So I'm going to talk about those
tools with you.
Six years ago when we had no idea what we
were doing online, we started a website called
GoAskNewton.com. It was the website dedicated
to education, bringing education to folks
around the world on basics of money. It's
still on by the way. GoAskNewton.com. And
we started reaching out to other people to
say, "Why don't you create content for our
website and talk about money?" These were
professional bloggers that were blogging about
money. And I noticed one of the messages we
got back that Mario shared with me, I'll never
forget the message. He said, Why would we
create content for your website when your
website is ranked 16 million on Alexa. You
know what 16 million is? It means my own father's
not visiting my website. That's what 16 million
means. He said, why would I take time to write
an article for your blog when my website is
ranked 400,000. That message in itself told
me everyone knows what type of a product you
have. So it made us take a step back and put
a very clear strategy together on what type
of a business and what type of a brand we
wanted to create to be authentic, to be real,
where you could say, "I'm proud to be a follower
of Valuetainment and call yourself a Valuetainer
because you know if you come here, the content
we're going to share with you is going to
be legit.
So let's get right into it. By the way, how
do you like my artwork? This is my Snapchat,
which looks nothing like Snapchat but that's
the best I could do. You can message me on
Snapchat Betdavid19. I always get back to
people on Snapchat. This is my Twitter, although
it's a little heavy-duty. Twitter needs to
go on a diet, and Instagram, and I think I
did a pretty good job on YouTube here.
So let's start off with Twitter.
Twitter's the easiest one to go through. So
Twitter is famous for a couple of things.
One of the things Twitter is famous for is
for having the most fake followers on the
website. It is #1 for the most fake accounts
out of all the social media platforms. This
is one of the reasons why people still haven't
bought Twitter. Twitter's been on the market
for a while. A lot of people said they were
going to buy it. No one's yet bought it. They're
not interested because there's way, way too
many fake accounts on Twitter. So what do
you do with Twitter? You're following people
on Twitter and you know, I have 200,000 followers
on Twitter. I have 300,000 followers on Twitter.
Man, that's crazy. How do I know if they're
real? There's a website called TwitterAudit.com,
which I put a link on the bottom of my website,
if you're watching this on YouTube, you come
to my website, you'll see TwitterAudit.com.
You click on TwitterAudit and test it out.
Test it out with somebody that you're following.
Put their name on there. I will guarantee
you, you will be shell shocked on how many
of their followers are real or not. Rule of
thumb is anything above 60, 70, 80 % is solid.
Anything below 50%, they have overly bought
some fake Twitter followers. And if anything
below 10 -15%, they're trying way too hard.
You know, it's like the boy back in school
that was afraid to walk around and he would
put some socks in his underwear to make himself
look like he was a little bit stronger than
he really was. Listen, for those of you that
buy fake Twitter followers, you're putting
socks, take the socks out and just man up
and maybe don't wear spandex would be your
safest bet on what to do. But the reality
part of it is today, everyone knows if you're
using a sock or not. Everybody. So go to TwitterAudit.com
and test it out. Test your own account, test
my account, test some other people's account.
Test some social media followers, some people
in your company, maybe some executives, and
you will realize how legit it is and how legit
is is not for some. But you need to know who's
doing it the proper way.
Twitter, you know, you can see if someone's
Twitter followers are fake if you just follow
it and you take a look at it and you'll see
they're following 900 people but only have
18 followers back. That's a fake account.
And if there's too many like that, it's a
trend. They bought fake followers. There's
a guy the other day who one of his executives
in his company reached out to me and he said,
hey, you know, this guy in the company, he's
saying that he got more followers in one day
than you had your entire career, and you know,
he's killing it on social media and I just
told him, I said, "Listen, man. How many followers?"
He said, 65,000 in one day.. And you only
have 64,900 Twitter followers. I said, first
of all, congratulations to him. Second, have
you ran a Twitter audit on him? And he said,
"What do you mean?" I said, why don't you
go onto TwitterAudit.com, and he goes on TwitterAudit,
and I said, put his name on there. He put
his name on there. I said, How many do you
see that are real? Two percent were real.
He was silent. I said, now test yours out.
He tested his out. Then he went another person
and said, "these are real." And I said, yes,
it's because it's very easy for Twitter to
track nowadays who's fake and who's not, because
their investors are requiring them to know
who is real and not, so all these fake people,
people are now tracking. He backed up and
said, "I apologize so much, such and such
and I said, Look, Twitter's not a platform
that works very well for us. Some people do
very well on Twitter. Some people don't do
very well on Twitter, which I'm going to highlight
on the end, which is what you should do with
your own brand. But just know when some people
are putting the fake stuff out there, you've
got to read between the B.S. that everybody
wants to be a celebrity and this and that,
"I announced a podcast and everyone's following
me now." Listen, it doesn't work that way.
Social media, to build a brand, it's a five-year
game plan. It's not something you do in six
months or three months or put up one video
and you're a celebrity. I wish it was that
way. It doesn't work that way. If it was that
way, everybody would be well-known, and everybody
would have millions of subs on YouTube, but
there's work that goes behind it, right? So
that's that part here with Twitter to keep
in mind.
So there's websites out there, many websites.
Just go on Google and type in buy Twitter
followers. Buy Twitter followers. Okay? I
have one here, I don't want to give them credit
because I don't want to endorse this habit.
This is one that Mario and them pulled up.
You can buy 1,000 followers for $7. You can
buy 50,000 followers for $130. You can buy
a million followers for $1299. And on there
it says real followers. What they mean by
real followers is there are people all day
that create these accounts that follow people
that are really set up by real human beings
and then they have a bot that goes and follows
you and it takes one week for you to get a
million followers. And you pay $1299 for that.
It does very well. It's almost like those
credit repair guys that know how to boost
your credit score for one week when you're
trying to get the loan, and then it goes back
to 499. That's kind of what it is, except
here, everyone knows you have fake followers
today with TwitterAudit.com.
So just know the difference and follow the
authentic people on social media who are actually
making an effort to do it the right way. There's
plenty of them out there that are doing it
the right way. And if you do it right and
you bring value, you know, you're not trying
to con people and all that stuff, eventually
you'll get a lot of proper followers.
Next, let's talk about YouTube. YouTube is
a little bit different. Let me tell you why
YouTube's a little bit different. They don't
play. YouTube does not play. So if you try
to play games with YouTube, they will simply
shut down your account. When I tell you they'll
shut down your account, they will shut down
your account, especially if you're trying
to monetize it. So there's a lot of same thing
- you can buy YouTube views. If you buy YouTube
views, we are a verified account with YouTube.
So we work with Creator Studio for YouTube,
they have the YouTube Creators I think it's
called where you go and once you're part of
a group, and I think we just participate in
their silver because we got 100,000 subs.
So you get support, you get all this other
stuff. And then you don't want to be flagged.
If you're flagged, you lose your opportunity
so you can check to see which brands are flagged
or not. Here's a few simple rules that I follow
with YouTube channels. If the YouTube channel
has chosen to hide their subscribers and comments,
I'm concerned. I don't do any business with
anybody if their YouTube channel has hidden
subscribers and comments. Here's why. Our
comments are wide open. Many years ago we
had to make a decision. Three years ago whether
we'd leave it open or keep it private. I said,
why keep it private? Pat, what if somebody
says something bad about you? What is they
do? We're not trying to get everybody in the
world to like us. We're trying to make sure
to do our part. We bring value to you. If
you like it, you stick around, if you don't,
go to another place. We're okay with that.
It's competition. And you make us keep getting
better and we have to get your attention.
And I'm creating content that I believe pound
for pound we can go against anybody. That's
why you keep coming back. That's my job, right?
And we're going to do that. I don't know how
long we're going to keep creating content.
I may go three more months, six more months,
12 more months. But I'm still creating content
on YouTube, right? So any time I see a YouTube
channel that's hidden its subs or hidden its
comments, I don't do any business with them.
By the way, the other day a kid called me
- the kid that was here. Do you [Mario] remember
what his name was, the kid that was here?
He flew in and did an interview, brought a
camera guy and his YouTube channel had 1400
subs. But I liked him and I said, No problem,
I'll give you an hour interview. He did the
interview and was actually a very good interviewer
and asked a lot of good questions. I said
okay to him and I told Mario, no problem.
Why? Because he was authentic, he was real,
he was transparent. He was open and you could
tell he's not really killing it, but I LOVE
the fact that he doesn't have a problem saying,
"Look, I'm really trying. That's honest to
me. I want to do business with people like
that. And believe it or not, the players at
the top on YouTube they're not lightweights.
They can read everything. They know every
single thing. They're the same exact way as
well.
So don't worry if you don't have that stuff
going on.
Here's another thing. Look at ratios. What
do I mean by ratios? If you look at a video
that's got 100,000 views, but it's only got
49 likes, they bought views. If a video's
got 100,000 views, but it's only got 50 comments,
they bought views. Okay? It's not possible.
Those ratios don't make sense. So you've got
to pay attention to that on how that works
out.
I'll give you one tool for YouTube. It's called
SocialBlade.com Social Blade is unbelievable.
I believe it's the number one tool for anybody
that's wanting to verify other YouTube channels
or you have your own YouTube channel, Social
Blade is #1, because it tells you, you can
literally pick three different channels, like
yourself and two other channels, and size
yourself up against different channels. And
find out how many subs you're getting per
day, and how many views you're getting per
day. And how many minutes you're getting per
day vs. your competitors. And they'll literally
put the whole chart together for you for free.
Social Blade. Phenomenal. You can go and look
at some subs and again, I'll run this, and
some companies don't come up because they
made it private, and I don't do any business.
It's shut down for me. I don't feel that company's
being transparent or that individual's being
transparent. And any time somebody's trying
to be too secretive about the public time
nowadays, look, we don't need to do business.
That's the way I do business. You can choose
to do business with that. I choose not to
do business with that.
If I'm going to do business with you, I need
to know exactly where you stand with your
content you're creating. Social Blade, you
will fall in love with, again, if you get
on there. And by the way, you know, YouTube
has certain termination guidelines on what
they terminate their YouTube channels for.
Dennis, let's put the link to that as well
on the bottom, you'll see termination guidelines
for YouTube. YouTube's a professional company.
They're owned by Google and they're very,
very professional when you do business with
them. No one's perfect, but we like doing
business with them as well. And obviously,
YouTube there's plenty if you search for buy
YouTube views, tons of websites will come
up. I'm not going to give you too much credit
to this next one here.
Then let's go to websites. I have a lot of
people that will say things like, "I have
thousands of people every day that come on
my website and visit my website." And I'm
like, "Wow, that's impressive. And then you
go on Alexa.com and it shows their website
that is ranked 13 million. You know how many
people visit a website if it's ranked 13 million?
One to five a day. And one of them is themselves.
So you've just got to keep that in mind. So
you can't just say I get tens of thousands
of people that visit my website and I get
so many questions and requests, it's just
not possible. Amateurs will buy into it. It's
almost like a 40-year-old man trying to fool
a 18-year-old girl how amazing you are. You're
not going to fool a 33-year-old woman. It's
just going to happen. And some people that
are in the social media side that I kind of.
. . they're questionable on their approach
and who they prey, on who they're trying to
get money out of. These 18-year-old people
to give them $8,000, $5,000 - I have a very
difficult time with that way of doing business.
I like sleeping on a soft pillow. I really
like a soft pillow. I like to sleep with a
half a second when I lay down. And if I take
money from that 18 , 19-year-old kid, yes,
he may pay me 10 grand, but do I really want
to have him go to his mom, dad, for credit
cards? I don't want to be doing that. I don't
want to be doing that. I don't recommend you
do it either. You don't need to build your
business or brand that way to get big. Believe
me, there's a lot of people that are doing
the right way. So Alexa. Alexa.com will tell
you a website's ranking. Believe me, we have
our team that gets the reports all the time.
We size ourselves up on where we're at to
grow our business. We have certain other people
that we compete ourselves with to grow our
business to the next level. But there's a
website out there called WeeklyM.com. I have
a link on the bottom that takes you exactly
to where you can put the rank of a website
and it tells you exactly how many visitors
they get monthly. So it will tell you, if
you're ranked 10 million, it means you get
maybe one visitor a day. If you're ranked
one million, you're getting 1500 visitors
per month. If you're ranked 100,000, it means
you're getting 30,000 visitors per month.
And then you can go down and you'll see all
the other numbers. But it's a very good tool
to use. It's not Alexa, it's actually WeeklyM
that gives you the Alexa numbers on there.
So now let's go to Instagram. One of the things
I like that Instagram did in 2014, they called
it Instagram Purge. Because as much as Twitter
had a lot of fake accounts, and one of the
reasons I believe Twitter is not getting bought
out is because they're not willing to purge
their accounts. They need to purge all the
fake accounts today. Today! Twitter, Jake,
look at me, Jack! Purge those accounts! Today!
When they [Instagram] purged their accounts,
they were bought like this. You've got to
purge those accounts, even if somebody's numbers
get very, very small. You've got to purge
all those accounts. So Instagram in 2014 said,
No, we're doing a purge. It's like doing an
audit. Next thing you know, somebody with
100,000 Instagram followers went all the way
down to 18,000 followers. Why? There were
82,000 fake followers. Now there were a lot
of fake bots back in the days with Instagram
that everybody took a hit on that. It wasn't
just you. Everybody, porn and all this other
stuff, so Instagram had to clean that up.
Twitter still has that. They haven't cleaned
it up because the numbers look good. They
need to get rid of that and just man up and
woman up and make sure everybody knows, listen,
we're transparent and this is who we are.
If they did that, their valuation would go
up. People would actually look at them and
trust them. Instagram did that, and next thing
you know, everybody started saying, "Wow,
I can't fake Instagram any more. And I think
they're going to do a purge again sometime
this year. I think they did a small one but
not a bigger one. It's coming up. Now Instagram
has a lot of bots that people use. Some of
them are effective, but for the most part
with Instagram, there's way too much fake
stuff that's out there. Again, I don't recommend
it, it's not effective, two, it doesn't work
anymore with Instagram. They did a very smart
thing. They're owned by Facebook. So Facebook
doesn't play around. You try to do something
fake with Facebook, and they catch you, they're
not a big fan of it. Facebook has the same
thing, you can buy fake fans and all that
other stuff. Believe me, there's so many things
you can do with Facebook as well, on the fake
side. You'll see some Facebook fan pages that
have a million fans, and you're like, wow,
this Facebook fan page has a million likes,
but every time they post a picture, three
likes, two likes, one like, eight likes, seven
likes. Not good ratios. And you've got some
guys that are doing a very good job, and they're
advertising a lot. No problem. You've got
to advertise and use some resources to get
your name out. That's a right way of doing
it. You can do that, and Facebook's pretty
good if you do that part of it with them.
Podcasters - there are a lot of great podcasters
out there. John Lee Dumas is one of the best
podcasters, Entrepreneur on Fire, I was on
John Lee Dumas' Entrepreneur on Fire, recently
and he's one of the best, I believe if not
the best podcast for entrepreneurs out there.
And he's got millions of downloads that people
have. And you can always check people as well
on podcasts. And there's a website called
Podtrac - P O D T R A C. com I'm going to
put the link on the bottom as well for you
to check. Do your part. Don't just say, Oh,
this was great. Do your own study. Do your
own research. And support people that are
doing it the right way. And if you're trying
to create your own brand, do it the right
way. Believe me, people are not dumb. People
know what's going on. People are a lot more
educated, especially if you want the real
quality following. They kind of know what's
going on.
And last but not least, Snapchat. Snapchat,
you can't buy anything. You know why? Because
no one knows anyone's numbers anyway, so who
cares? That's one good thing about Snapchat.
There's nobody selling anything to buy some
new friends, nothing. No one cares. No one
knows. You have no idea how many followers
celebrities have. You have no idea how many
views. No one has any idea. So they've made
themselves private for a long time. And they're
doing a pretty good job. They're figuring
out ways to improve. Although they're struggling
a little bit with ads, but I have a feeling
they're going to figure it out because they're
doing it the right way. These guys [Twitter]
need a miracle. I'm thinking about doing a
video for Twitter, a message directed to Jack,
for us to share this video with everybody.
I want to have a meeting with Jack to tell
him exactly. I love Twitter, but I hate what
they're doing. I almost feel like for the
people that are social media people, man,
we've got to fix this thing and make sure
it sticks around. So who knows. I'm not sure
if I'll do the video or not, but stay tuned
and maybe it will come out here pretty soon
on what we can do to save Twitter from not
going and being MySpace. Maybe that's the
title by the way, how to prevent Twitter from
being MySpace. That's not a bad title, Dennis.
What do you think? I like that.
So, again, look, I did all this stuff for
you because many of you asked who to follow,
who not to follow. Just use these tools to
check it for yourself, who's real or not,
and eventually, don't try to be dominant on
all of them. I'm not myself. You know, for
Twitter, I only have 64,900 followers and
we had to try so many creative ways to get
followers to search keywords, entrepreneur
and all that. We hired people. But Twitter
is good, but it's not great for us. Instagram
is okay for us. Instagram is very good. This
morning I was with my personal trainer who
is a body builder, he's a professional body
builder, he's 6' 1" 285. So just try to figure
this out. 6' 1", 285. And they do well on
Instagram because it's all physique, look,
pictures, image, that works. But a message
may be a little bit different. Snapchat, YouTube,
figure out what works for you, and make that
your main play. Some people say, "I can be
good on all of them." Look, just like in sports,
remember when kids were athletic, remember
some kids were very good in all sports? My
son can pretty my play any sport. But if you
want your kid to be great, he's got to pick
one sport. So pick one of these and make it
your best platform. Be adaptable in case something
crazy happens like Jack's not preparing Twitter,
then you know how to make your own audibles
as well.
So with that being said, Dennis, let me get
my favorite pillow. We are making some rearrangements
on our goals. We've been saying by June 30
of 2017 we'll be a quarter million subs. We're
going to get there way before. We're going
to make a little bit of an audacious goal.
We believe we'll get to a million subs before
the end of 2017, because we plan on taking
this channel to a completely different level.
I'm talking in a completely - wait until you
see the projects and individuals and the collaborators
we're going to bring to you for you to know,
when you think about the word, "entrepreneur,"
and you want to go to one stop to have any
of your questions answered, for free, you're
going to come to Valuetainment. You'll see
why. So if you haven't seen more than one
video please subscribe and watch some of the
other videos and try us out. And if you've
got any questions, comments or thoughts about
today's video, comment on the bottom and if
you watch this video on a completely different
website, you can always come back to PatrickBetDavid.com
boom and you get all the content on there.
Take care everybody. Bye bye.